wow yeah mold probably should be in here
no we
shouldn't
[Music]
I was born in Jonesboro Arkansas and
live with my grandparents until I was
six after moving to Wisconsin I would
still often spend Summers with my
grandparents I remember days spent by
the river and nights walking along dirt
roads while discussing the
constellations
overhead and I remember that it was
sometime before the year 2000 when they
bought this 64 acre property in the
Ozarks it was meant to be an off-grid
Haven in addition to their actual
home just in case you know the world
went to hell
over time my grandparents had at a few
small cabins ouses work sheds and a main
two-story
cabin they also installed water tanks
and dug a well and even had a windmill
brought in for generating
electricity but the lights never did
turn
on and though the well struck water
there was never enough power to pull it
up because
my grandpa got
sick really
[Music]
sick he passed away while they were
still in the building
stages and though my grandma and family
would go up every now and then over time
it just became forgotten and nature
began moving
[Music]
in
all the time that it has sat up here you
would just want to take that insulation
out because it's had it's been hot and
cold and moisture right basically they
never finished the walls they just put
the insulation up look at this
fan that's the fan you still have that
fan
yep oh my gosh IED that fan I didn't
know was up I love that fan you want it
Dad we go to garage sales and just buy
stuff for up here all the time over the
years trespassers have broken in and
stolen nearly everything even my
grandma's wedding
dress so only the basics
remained but these things still tell a
story rows of beans and rice stored in
plastic Coke bottles lining the walls of
nearly every cabin travel siiz bottles
of shampoo and conditioner that are 20
if not 30 years old random Treasures
that have been collected from garage
sales since the
1960s relics from another
time seeing it all here in person was
wild and it was also just kind of sad
to see what was once a
dream be so clearly lost to
time so they dug a well but they were
never able actually to get water up but
there is water down there that was
confirmed and then this is the outdoor
shower that they built there faucet over
there tank poison
ivy there's another cabin
back here that we're walking
to yeah this
is wow that's why they but this one
could be cleaned I bet my grandpa was
the kind of guy who wrapped his cash in
tin foil to keep the government from
knowing what he
had before he died we watched The Bucket
List together and I asked him what three
things would be on his own
list he said he would have liked to let
live in a teepee for a year or wander
the Australian Outback with only the
essentials and horses he wished he had
spent more time with
horses everything with him felt like a
grand
Adventure even the smallest
things he meant so much to me and left
this world far too
soon coming back to this place was
emotional for me in a lot of ways even
though I'd only been here a handful of
times all of them more than 20 years
[Music]
ago I didn't know what to expect but I
was definitely not prepared for what we
found
this this is wild look at all this
baking soda why is there so much baking
soda it's so good
wow it's right there below below this
thing that's look at all the nuts in
here they've been storing this would be
a big cleanup project before I would
even start to
build so much to clean
out here's the third
cabin oh my
gosh it's pretty bad yeah this one is
the worst but this one is the first one
you put up here oh the
smell
[Music]
mhm yeah
mold should be in here
oh spiders potential
[Music]
mhm hey there's out house right
here this is probably this cabin is
probably the the best shape doesn't
smell wet or
miloy looks like the roof is still
intact it's small
but this could potentially be a good
base for building out the bigger one if
I decide to do that look at that old
frosting cup wow feel like I'm at a
museum right well this has been up here
is it look at all these survival Foods
jeez these are like 20 years old
yeah 25 we're going to put some mice
straps in here and spray for
bugs and don't know when will be back
hoping
that this will
[Music]
help hi wait hi surprise it is 2 months
later and I'm back on the west coast bet
you didn't see that coming so the cabins
were in really bad shape most of them
probably not worth keeping it wasn't a
total deal breaker for me because I was
still open to saving what I could but
otherwise just rebuilding from the
ground up but as it turns out the land
itself is worth a lot we didn't actually
have it appraised but judging by other
listings in the area potentially north
of $1 to
$200,000 and even though it's in the
family the land is part of my mom and
aunt's inheritance and their kids which
does include me but still really only
works if I pay market value for the
property so considering the cost of the
land how much work it would require and
all the upfront costs of clearing a road
and pulling water and installing solar
and propane and all the things it just
didn't really make sense especially
because it's so remote like building a
community would be tough and my family
would still be over an hour drive away
and I would be so so far from the places
that I really love but I won't lie it
was a tough pill to
swallow I think I had just become really
attached to the idea of kind of picking
up where my grandpa had left off and
learning how to build something off grid
and I know it's a really popular
pipeline for road lifers to then
transition to buying land and building
it and that is a dream I'm still
interested in in but um this one this
just wasn't it and it was a
really tough thing to come to terms with
because it seemed so aligned you know it
seemed to come out of nowhere and it
seemed just like the next step but it
wasn't meant to be and that's okay I
spent the second half of October in
Missouri with my family and that alone
was definitely worth a trip out east I
didn't film much but I would love to go
back sometime in the summer and spend
time with them on the river it's just so
uniquely different from the Landscapes
out
west I did still seriously consider
moving to Missouri primarily because I
have family there and I would love to
spend more time with them there's also
the fact that it's just wildly cheaper
to live in the midwest or the South than
it is to live on the west coast in
Missouri I would have the option of
buying something outright that would be
modern and comfortable whereas on the
west coast my options are more limited
after spending just a few weeks there I
found that I was deeply deeply missing
the Landscapes of the West and I know
that might seem really obvious like we
all knew that was going to happen part
of me felt that after traveling and
living on the road for so long I would
be in a space where I could have some
distance but that just wasn't the case I
also began to realize that work would
look pretty different as well like I
would be flying to a of destinations in
order to film and photograph which would
also mean additional costs for flights
and airbnbs and rental cars and all
these things that I don't have to stress
over right now when I have my van and I
can easily just drive from one beautiful
location to the next so overall it was a
learning experience it was an amazing
time with family and I'm so glad that I
went my next Grand idea was to travel
internationally all winter So my aunt
offered to let me park my van at her
house and both she and my mom have
Airline benefits and I fly standby
mostly for free so I was like this is it
I'm going overseas I applied for a
handful of month-long house hits in
Switzerland and the UK and I had great
conversations with a few of them they
seemed like a slam dunk but in the end
they all felt more comfortable going
with someone local which I totally
understand it makes sense but was also a
bummer so I thought okay I'll just book
a month-long Airbnb and travel that way
it's really no different than paying
rent in the US but I get to experience
new countries and cities and all that so
I started browsing possible locations
and I tried imagining what I would do
once I got there and honestly I just
wasn't that excited going by myself just
didn't sound that fun which is an
interesting plot twist because I can
genuinely say that up until not that
long long ago I truly wanted nothing
more than to be alone but now I've
reached this point where I'm like wait I
actually kind of want to experience this
wild stuff with someone I don't know who
but yeah I will say that if I had never
been to Europe before I would absolutely
push myself to go alone or not but I've
spent a fair amount of time overseas
living overseas especially in Europe and
at this point I don't really have an
interest in going somewhere just to go
I've spent so much of my life traveling
and moving around I've actually lived in
37 places like legit address changes I
actually keep a spreadsheet of all my
former addresses because I was once
interrogated at the UK border and I
couldn't remember my last five addresses
correctly and that didn't go over so
well so I created a spreadsheet anyway
my point is travel is a huge part of my
identity and something I will probably
always love but what I'm craving right
now more than anything at least lately
is to go home I just don't know where
that is yet or to house set overseas
because that to me would be a new and
different experience unlike booking a
hotel or Airbnb you're basically plucked
down into the life of a local and you
get to hang out with their pets and walk
around their neighborhood and meet their
neighbors and sometimes they'll invite
you over for dinner or to go for a hike
and you get to really experience the
location from a whole other perspective
than if you're say traveling as a
tourist so that is definitely still on
the table but as it stands all of this
basically landed me right back where I
started in trying to decide what to do
and where to go next so I did what I
often do in these situations and I hi
High tailed it to a place that feels
like home and that place was yosity I
spent about a week just hiking and
hanging out and refle Ing and I realized
that this cycle of questioning is kind
of an annual thing it's a feeling that
tends to surface when the nights are
longer and I'm forced to spend more time
alone inside my van with my thoughts
it's almost like a yearly review one
where the underlying question is is this
still fun because most of us don't get
on the road thinking this is it I'm
doing this forever like we get on the
road thinking I'll do this until I don't
want to do it anymore or for some I'll
do this until I don't have to anymore
and so it's kind of this constant
underlying question do I still want to
live in this van I don't think that
question will ever go away until the day
I don't live in this van but I will say
this I love this van it's my home and it
does give me anxiety to think about not
having it however what I want in my life
right now is
routine stability consistency and
Community I could also also really use
some health insurance which I haven't
had since
2018 but that's a topic I will say for
another
[Music]
video right now living on the road
probably takes up about 40% of my energy
on a daily basis finding safe and
accessible places to sleep that are at
least somewhat flat and also have
relative access to water and groceries
internet showers track cash laundry
shipping options for work packages
Sunshine for solar and non- creepy
neighbors daily tasks include building a
bed and work desk cleaning the dishes
with cold water emptying the toilet and
gray water tank driving monitoring
battery levels researching and planning
routes checking the weather listening to
ATVs and/ or generators but also fan
life is great I love it a big motivator
for me right now is that I just want
greater access to the places I love
which put simply I want a 4x4 I want to
go film The sieras in the winter and
other snowy locations and drive up to
Alaska maybe or just roam around remote
places in the canyon lands I want to
film and photograph some harder to reach
places I also want to go backpacking and
leave my car at the trail head without
worrying about my vehicle my home and
literally everything I own getting
stolen all at once and truthfully that's
just not possible with my current setup
so here are my thoughts one option is to
sell the van get a home base and a 4x4
SUV similar to my old setup so that I
can still travel for weeks at a time and
also have a vehicle for getting around
town another possibility is to get a
truck camper and remain full-time I
think if I do that it'll probably be
after a year or two of living in a house
or apartment first because otherwise I
would kind of just be trading like one
set of problems for another I could also
just sell the van pack a bag and Float
around overseas but again that doesn't
really satisfy my current need for
routine stability and community that
brings us to the easiest path which is
to just do nothing and see if this
feeling fades in the spring like it
always does after yosity I drove down to
Big Sir and spent a good amount of time
along the coast just soaking up the
sunshine because what I ultimately
decided to do is to commit to a
two-month house in Washington which I am
at right now and it is currently week
two my thought behind this is to see how
I feel after two months in one place
during the darkest and rainiest part of
the year right now the jury's still out
because I am loving the stability but
we'll see what happens come February you
can probably expect more videos from me
over the next few weeks because I'll
actually have time to edit and I'm
currently working on a van tour that I
filmed on the trip up here guess this
has just been a little life update um
wanted to share about the cabins and I
also just wanted to be transparent and
honest about what I'm going through
especially for all my fellow Ries out
there you are not alone if you're also
feeling a little unsure of what comes
next I think it's just all part of the
journey and I feel like I've been
talking for 10 hours tldr everything and
nothing at all has changed I'm so
grateful to all of you for tuning in and
watching and I hope you all have a
beautiful holiday I love you guys and
I'll see you soon my hands are freezing
ow
[Music]
dude